الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد
قامت الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله
الا
الله شا
الله
جك استقيم واست تر يرحمكم
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم اياك
نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم و
الضالين
امين من
جاء بالحسنه فله عشر امثال
ومن شاء بال فلا يجزى الا مثلها وهم لا
يظلمون قل انني هداني ربي الى
صراط
مستقيم دينا قيما مله ابراهيم حنيفا وما
كان من
المشركين قل ان صلاتي ونسكي ومحياي ومماتي
لله رب
العالمين لا شريك له وبذلك امرت وانا اول
المسلمين قل اغير الله ابغي ربا وهو رب كل
شيء ولا تكسب كل نفس الا
عليها زره وزر
اخرى ثم الى ربكم مرجعكم
فينبئكم بما
كنتم
مختلفون وهو الذي جعلكم
خلائف الارض ورفع بعضكم فوق بعض درجات
ليبل
اكم ان ربك سريع العقاب
وانه
لغفور
رحيم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا
الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ان الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات كانت
لهم جنات الفردوس
نزلا خالدين فيها لا يبغون عنها
حولا قل لو كان البحر مدادا لكلمات ربي
لنفد البحر قبل ان تنفد كلمات ربي ولو
جئنا بمثله
مددا قل
ان بشر مثلكم يوحى الي انما الهكم اله
واحد فمن كان يرجو
لقاء ربه فليعمل عملا
صالحا ولا يشرك بعبا ده ربه
احدا الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله
اكبر سمع الله الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر الله
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اللهب
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
السلام علي
وبركاته ان شا الله
t قم صراح ان شاء الله صلاه العش ان شاء
الله صلاه
العيد صلا
ان شاء الله
تكب
7030 ان شاء اللهن الله
تعالى
الله ان شاء الله جزاك
الله
[Silence]
‏s
بسم
الله
استقيم
واست الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
وقل رب اعوذ بك من همزات
الشياطين واعوذ بك رب ان
يحضرون حتى اذا
جاء احدهم الموت قال ربي
ارجعون لعلي اعمل صالحا فيما تركت كلا
انها كلمه هو
قائلها ومن ورا
م الى يوم
ثون فاذا نفخ في الصور فلا انساب بينهم
يومئذ ولا
يتساءلون فمن فمن
خفت فمن ثقلت موازينه
فاولئك هم
المفلحون ومن خفت موازينه ف اولئك الذين
خسروا انفسهم في جهنم
خالدون تلفح وجوههم النار وهم فيها
كالحون الم تكن اياتي تتلى عليكم
فكنتم بها
تكذبون قالوا ربنا غلبت علينا شقوتنا وكنا
قوم
الضالين ربنا اخرجنا منها فان عدنا فانا
ظالمون قال اخسؤوا في ولا
تكلموا الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حم
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
الالين
امين قال اخسؤوا فيها ولا
تكلمون انه كان فريق من عبادي يقولون ربنا
امنا فاغفر لنا وارحمنا وانت خير
الراحمين اتخذتم وهم سخريا حتى
انسوكم ذكري
وكنتم منهم
تضحكون اني جزيتهم اليوم بما صبروا انهم
هم
الفائزون قال كم لبثتم في الارض عدد
سنين قالوا لبثنا يوما او بعض يوم فاسال
ال
دين قال ان لبثتم الا قليلا لو انكم كنتم
تعلمون افحسبتم
انما خلقناكم عبثا وانكم الينا لا
ترجعون فتعالى الله الملك الحق لا اله الا
هو رب العرش الكريم
ومن يدع مع الله الها اخر لا برهان له به
فانما حسابه عند
ربه انه لا يفلح
الكافرون وقل رب اغفر وارحم وانت خير
الراحمين الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله استقيم
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
وناه الشعر ينبغي له ان هو الا ذكر
وقران مبين
لينذر من كان حيا ويحق القول على
الكافرين اولم يروا انا خلقنا
لهم ما عملت ايدينا
انعاما فهم لها
مالكون
للنا فمنها ركوبهم ومنها
كلون
ولهم فيها منافع ومشارب افلا
يشكرون
و من دون الله
الهه
ينصرون لا
يستطيعون نصر وهم لهم
جند
محضرون فلا يحزنك قولهم انا يعلم ما يسرون
وما
يعلنون
الانسان انا خلقناه من نطفه فاذا هو خصيم
مبين وضرب لنا مثلا ونسي خلقه قال من يحيي
العظام وهي
رميم قل يحيي الذي انشاها اول مره وهو بكل
خلق
عليم الذي جعل لكم من الشجر الاخضر نارا
فاذا
انتم منه
توقنون اوليس الذي خلق السماوات والارض
بقادر على ان يخلق
مثلهم بلى وهو الخلاق
العليم انما امره اذا اراد شيئا ان يقول
له كن
فيكون فسبحان الذي بيده ملكوت كل شيء
واليه
ترجعون الله الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
اكبر الله الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ولله ملك السماوات والارض ويوم تقوم
الساعه يومئذ يخسر
المبطلون وت كل امه
جايه كل
امه تدعى الى كتابها اليوم تجزون ما
كنتم
تعملون هذا ك ينطق عليكم بالحق انا كنا
نستنسخ ما كنتم
تعملون فاما الذين امنوا وعملوا صالحات
فيدخلهم ربهم في
رحمته ذلك هو الفوز
المبين واما الذين كفروا افلم تكن اياتي
متلى عليكم فاستكبروا
وكنتم قوما
مجرمين واذا قيل ان وعد الله حق والساعه
لا ريب فيها قلتم ما ندري ما الساعه ان
نظن الا
ظنا قلتم ما ندري ما الساعه ان نظن الا
ظنا وما نحن
بمسن وبد لهم سيئات ما عملوا وحاق بهم ما
كانوا به
يستهزئون
وقيل اليوم
ننساكم كما نسيتم
لقاء يومكم هذا وماواهم النار وما لكم من
ناصرين ذلكم بانكم اتخذتم ايات الله هزوا
وغرتكم الحياه
الدنيا فاليوم لا يخرجون منها ولا هم
يستعتبون له الحمد
السماوات رب الارض رب
العالمين وله
الكبرياء في السماوات
والارض وهو العزيز
الحكيم الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
‏st
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه والسلام
على رسول الله وعلى اله وصحبه
ومنوه ومن تبع باحسان الى يوم
الدين اللهم صل وسلم وبارك وعلى عبدك محمد
مه
[Silence]
الله
عليه
الصلام
[Silence]
‏so to
that
[Silence]
علح
‏come
عليه
عليهه
واللام come
back ان شا
الله الله سبحانه
وتالى way
عليه
so transmission
وي from الله سبحانه
وتالى
[Silence]
عليه
الله
[Silence]
سالح ‏by the way i this up you know this
is me sometimes i hear people and tell
me was alander great you
knower great was not any me you know
this
is
before empire was not
beli we don't know tr this man
was there another person namees up ‏is
and you see they always
around
great from
most worship the fire so who the
tr and way there
come allah hied him
and so they
about there
[Silence]
‏con
‏any
‏all are are
are
عليه
علسلام
كرانش ابر
رضي تقت رج
[Silence]
الله
‏is waking up what happ him
asking so these are things you know by
the way stories are just not
stor
liv
unfor
‏fr
know know i
things
know ‏not
askes
عليهه
عليه are
‏things
happ things things
[Silence]
things
الله
سالر finish the
day
for now that's something disc it seems
thing we do why
‏how
how
things let
meig person in your hous even the child
is one day old
‏pleas idea some
people
per make things
things
[Silence]
‏happ
سهال
any
[Silence]
‏make
sister
[Silence]
‏own
‏trans
[Silence]
‏they
wom
[Silence]
‏theu
‏tak
ال
الله
اللهه
all ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره
حسنه وقنا عذاب النار وقنا عذاب القبر ع
جنم ربنا
تقيم وتب علينا يا مولان الرحيم وصلى الله
على محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين برحمه
امين اللهم امين اللهم امين اللهم
[Silence]
امين
تراكم شاء
الله الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين
الصراطي صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
ولقد سبقت كلمتنا لعبادنا
المرسلين انهم لهم
المنظرون وان جندنا لهم
الغالبون فتولى عنهم حتى
حين وابصر فسوف يبصرون
افبعذابنا
يستعجلون فاذا نزل بساحتهم
فساء صباح
المنذرين وتولى عنهم حتى
ين وابصر فسوف
يبصرون سبحان ربك رب العزه عما
يصفون
وسلام على
المرسلين والحمد لله رب
العالمين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين
اهد
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين يا ايها الذين امنوا يا ايها
الذين امنوا اتقوا الله
ولتنظر نفس ما قدمت لغد ولتنظر ظر نفس ما
قدمت لغد واتقوا
الله ان الله خبير بما
تعملون ولا
تكون نسوا
فانساهم
انفسهم
اولئك هم
الفاسقون لا
يستوي اصحاب النار واص اصحاب
الجنه اصحاب
الجنه هم
الفائزون لو
انزلنا هذا القران على جبل لرايته
خاشعا لرايته
خاشعا
متصدعا من خشيه
الله وتلك الامثل
نضربها
للناس لعلهم
يتفكرون هو الله الذي
لا اله الا
هو هو الله الذي
لا اله الا هو عالم الغيب
والشهاده هو الرحمن
الرحيم هو الله الذي لا لا اله الا هو
الملك الملك القدوس السلام المؤمن المهيمن
العزيز
الجبار العزيز الجبار
المتكبر سبحان الله عما
يشركون هو الله الخالق البارئ المصور له
الاسماء الحسن
يسبح له ما في السماوات والارض وهو
العزيز وهو العزيز
الحكيم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله استقيم اعتدلوا
استو الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد اياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستق الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين رب اتيتني
علمتني من تاويل
الاحاديث فاطر السماوات والارض انت وليي
في الدنيا
والاخره توفني
مسلما
والحقني
بالصالحين ذلك من
انباء الغيب نوحيه
اليك وما كنت لديهم اذ
اجمعوا امرهم وهم
يمكرون وما اكثر الناس ولو حرست
بمؤمنين وما تسالهم عليه من اجر ان هو الا
ذكر
العالمين كاي من ايه في السماوات والارض
يمرون
عليها يمرون عليها وهم عنها
معرضون وما يؤمن
اكثرهم بالله الا وهم
مشركون افامنوا ان تاتيهم غا
من عذاب
الله او تاتيهم الساعه
بغته وهم لا
يشعرون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل هذه
سبيلي ادعوا الى
الله بصيره انا ومن
اتبعني
وسبحان الله
وما وان من
المشركين
وما ارسلنا من قبلك الا رجالا نوحي
اليه
نوحي اليهم من اهل
القرى افلم يسيروا في الارض
فينظروا كيف كان عاقبه الذين من قبل
ولدار الاخره ولدار الاخره خير للذين
اتقوا افلا
تعقلون حتى اذا س الرسل
وظنوا
انهم قد
كذبوا
جاءهم
جاءهم نصرنا
نشاء لا يرد باسنا عن القوم
المجرمين لقد كان في قصصهم عبره لولي
الالباب ما كان
حديثا
يفترى
ولا تص الذي بين يديه وتفصيل كل
شيء
وهدى ورحمه
لقوم
يؤمنون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله الشف الوتر ان شاء
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين سبح اسم ربك
الاعلى الذي خلق فسوى والذي قدر
فهدى
والذي اخرج المرعى فجعله
ثاء
احوى سنقرئك فلا
تنسى الا ما شاء
الله انه يعلم الجهر وما
يخفى ونيسرك لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت
الذكرى يذكر من يخشى
ويتجنب يصلى
النار
الكبرى ثم لا يموت فيها ولا
يحيا قد افلح من
تزكى وذكر اسم ربه فصلى
بل تؤثرون الحياه الدنيا
والاخره خير
وابقى
ان
هذا صحف
الاولى صحف
ابراهيم
و الله
اك سمع الله الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل
يا ايها
الكافرون لا اعبد ما
تعبدون
ولا انتم عابدون ما
اعبد
ولا انا عابد ما
عبدتم لكم دينكم ولي
دين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام
عليكم
الله الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
الين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد
ولم يولد ولم يكن له كفوا احد
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده ربنا ولك الحمد حمدا كثيرا طيبا
مباركا فيه مل السماء والارض ومل ما
بينهما ومل ما شئت من شيء بعد اهل الثناء
والمجد احق ما قال العبد وكلنا لك
عبد اللهم لا مانع لما اعطيت ولا معطي لما
منعت اللهم تم نورك فهديت فلك الحمد عظم
حلمك فعفوت فلك الحمد بسطت يدك فاعطيت فلك
الحمد فلك الحمد يا ربنا على كل
حال اللهم لك الحمد كما يسرت لنا صيام شهر
رمضان لك الحمد كما يسرت لنا قيام شهر
رمضان فتقبله منا يا رب
العالمين اللهم اختم لنا شهر رمضان
برضوانك والعتق من والعتق من نيرانك
واجعلنا يا ربنا من
المقبولين اللهم يا ربنا ويا موانا ويا
سميع الدعاء يا ذا المن
والعطاء يا ذا الجلال
والاكرام يا حي يا
قيوم اللهم اعده علينا اعواما مديده
وسنوات عديده ونحن بصحه وخير وعافيه ومن
نحب يا رب العالمين اللهم تقبل منا انك
انت السميع العليم تب علينا ان تواب
الرحيم عبيدك بنو عبيدك بنو امام نواصينا
بيدك ماض فينا حكمك عدل
فيك نسالك بكل اسم هو لك سميت به نفسك
انزلته في كتابك او علمته احدا من خلقك او
استاثرت به في علم الغيب عندك ان تجعل
القران العظيم ربيع
قلوبي نور صد وجلا احزاننا وذهاب
همومنا
وسابق جناتك جنات
الن اللهم ممن يقرا القران اناء الليل
واطراف النهار على الوجه الذي يرضيك عنا
رب
العالمين اللهم يا ربنا ويا مولانا ويا
سميع الدعاء يا ذا المن والعطاء يا ذا
الجلال والاكرام يا حي يا قيوم يا بديع
السماوات والارض ويا رحمن الدنيا
والاخره عجل بفرجك ونصرك لاخواننا
المستضافين المسلمين في كل مكان اللهم في
كل بقاع الارض اللهم في كل بقاع الارض
الله اللهم ضاقت كثرت عظم بلائهم وكثرت
حاجتهم فلا تتخلى عنهم يا رب العالمين نفس
كربهم وفرج همهم وكلهم معينا ونصيرا اللهم
خاصه وخصوصا في بلاد المق يا رب العالمين
في غزه وفلسطين اللهم كيد الغاصبين اللهم
رد كيد الغاصبين المحتلين اللهم انا ندرا
بك في
نحورهم ونعوذ بك من
اللهم تميرا عليهم فانهم لا يعجزونك يا رب
العالمين اللهم تقبل منا انك انت السميع
العليم وتب علينا انك انت التواب الرحيم
ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه
وقنا عذاب النار اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على
سيدنا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه والتابعين
واخر دعوانا
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
‏e